- Good morning Believe nation.
Today's message is hustle.
Over to you, Timothy Sykes.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- The key to being
successful is to work harder
than other people, 'cause
everybody wants success.
Everybody wants a Lamborghini.
Everybody wants freedom, but
what are you willing to do
to get there?
That's my question to you.
We're here at the most
prestigious university
in America, Harvard.
Fantastic, I'm very honored.
Thank you for having me here.
The people who have gotten here
have worked their butts off
to get here, but that's
just the beginning.
Whether you're in college or
you're going to go to college,
or you're out of college,
this is a lifelong journey
where you have to continually work hard,
work harder than other
people to get ahead.
A lot of people give
up at different times.
I'm no longer at that stage.
When I had my big loss,
I basically gave up.
For a year I was in the
gutter, but I came back.
And I said, "You know what?
"This was a mistake that I made investing.
"It wasn't the patterns.
"I didn't go against
what I learned to make
"all my millions before this loss.
"I invested," and I didn't
do my full due diligence,
and that was my mistake.
I eventually got back into trading.
I saw more patterns, and
I became the number one
lane trader at a 50,000 on
Covestor in 2007 to 2011.
- Every time I think about this message,
I think about Jerry Seinfeld,
and one of my favorite
bits of advice from Jerry
Seinfeld is you need to find
the thing that most
people consider torture.
It's the torture that you can endure,
where, when people look at your schedule,
they would see it as torturous.
Look at what I do.
Look what I do on Youtube.
So many people write in,
they Tweet me, they email me
asking, "How do you do so many videos?
"I'm having a hard time
doing one video a week".
It's torture.
If you were to look up my
schedule, it would be torture.
Making three videos at least a day,
going to the Youtube channel
on top of responding to
all the comments that come in.
We get hundreds of comments
every day that we respond to,
on top of keeping track of
all the requests, right,
from the top 10 series we
have over 2,500 requests,
and we keep track of it.
We keep note and see how many people voted
for different people, and then
we start making those videos,
on top of coming up with new series ideas
for what we can test out.
It'd be so easy just to
keep with the same formula,
but it's not enough.
It's got to get better.
We got to grow.
We got to improve.
It's torture.
You would look at our schedule and say,
"There's no way I want
to do that much work,"
but it's why I've gotten better.
It's why I went from the worst
summit agency to the best,
because, while everybody
else was having trouble
doing one video a week, I was
doing multiple videos a day.
It's that hustle, and it's
not to say that I'm great.
Anybody can accomplish it.
You just have to find
the thing that you can do
that would look like
torture to other people,
so, as an example, I had
Neil Pasricha on my channel.
We did his top 10 together, and afterwards
we were talking about his book.
He has a book.
It sold over a million copies,
and he was giving me advice
on how to sell a book, and
one of the bits of advice
that he gave me was he would
go to all the book stores
around in the general area,
and in Toronto we've got
a lot of different book stores,
and find out if they had
at least one copy of the book in store,
and he would drive there, and
he would talk to the manager,
and he would sign the book,
and he would have stickers
that said signed by author, and
he would chat up the manager
and talk about why he made
this book, and they would,
because of that conversation,
profile a little bit more
at the store, and, when
people came in and asked them
for a book, they would
give that recommendation,
and so that's how he would spend his days,
driving to different
book stores, chatting up
the different managers, signing the books,
putting the stickers on,
and I look at that work.
I think that is torture. (laughs)
I couldn't do it.
I would hate to do that,
to drive two hours to go
to a book store that had
two copies of my book,
to sign those books,
and chat up the manager
to get him or her to know me,
so they'll recommend the book
and put it higher up, and
do that day in, day out.
I couldn't do it.
It's torture,
but that's what he did,
that's what he does,
and that's how he's grown
and created a business
around his book and his speaking now,
and he's gone all in on
that, and it's amazing.
You need to find the same thing for you.
You need to find the thing you
can dedicate so much time to,
that you can hustle so hard at
that's it's, one, enjoyable.
As much as it may seem torturous for you
to jump into my Youtube
schedule, I like it.
I enjoy the work I'm doing.
I look forward to video day.
I look forward to looking at the comments.
I look forward to seeing what new topics
we can come up with.
I like it, and that's how we get better,
so what is the thing that
you can do constantly
and still get fueled by
and improve and get better
and create more value that
other people would look at
and say, "That is torture"?
That's the question of the day.
Question of the day: what
is a thing that you do,
that you hustle so hard at,
that nobody's going to touch you
'cause it's torture for everybody else?
Leave it in the comments below.
Then we'll join in discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Ken Ritchie.
Ken, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying reading it.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
Hey, Believe nation, for
those of you who want
a little extra motivation on hustling,
I've included some bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- People can look at me, and
it almost pisses them off.
They'll tell us, "That guy gets results?
"I'm pissed," right, and
kind of piss them off,
and then they got to deny
it to themselves and stuff.
Yeah, they can even see videos.
They'll go and say, "That's
a actress. It can't be.
"He's uglier than me and he's got a girl?
"Actress," right?
No, dude.
You just didn't go out.
I did, you didn't.
I've actually thought sometimes
of creating a video called
What I Did While You Didn't Do It or
What I Was Doing While You Were, no, no.
I was thinking of calling
it What I Was Doing
While You Were Doing What You Were Doing,
and I was going to enact the whole thing,
so I'd show what you
were doing: watching TV.
Like this, what I was doing:
me just hustling through
my life, going through my boring,
little, menial, repetitive
tasks that I do every (audio cuts out) day
that improve me 0.000001%
and that add up over time.
I really think I should
make a video of myself
just going through my day
and just show me doing it
every (audio cuts out)
day so people can see
the menial, slow, boring
nature of progress,
because, for every
public victory you have,
you have a private victory.
For every kick (audio cuts
out) video I put up online,
there's those hundreds of
hours that I spent at home
looking at my video footage,
looking at other speakers,
comparing it, contrasting
it, and learning how
to be a better speaker.
For every hot seat video you
see of me where I do some epic
(audio cuts out) that blows
your mind, there's all that time
that I spent going out
doing menial, little
bull (audio cuts out) approaches
again and again and again
and then going home and
looking at what I did
and how I could improve it, and on and on.
For every kick (audio cuts
out) freaking out boot camp
student that I have
that loved the program,
there's those (audio cuts
out) 50 weekends a year
that I went out and taught,
learned every little nuance
of the (audio cuts out) thing
again and again and again
for a decade.
That's kind of like what success is like,
I hope that I provide an
example of a guy who is
untalented, funny-looking, and
shouldn't be able to do it,
and is stunting on all your
(audio cuts out) faces,
(audience laughs)
and that you can see
that and say, "Oh, shit,
"if that little (audio cuts
out) can do it, I can do it".
- [Interviewer] How early in life
did your relentless ambition begin?
Did this happen when you were very young?
You alluded to the fact
that you sold papers
at age six or something.
- I don't know.
I don't really feel
like I'm that ambitious.
- [Interviewer] Come on,
I'd hate to follow you
around for a week.
I'd be in a tomb somewhere.
- Yeah, well, I just work hard,
but I know a lot of people
that work hard.
My father worked hard and
set an example for me,
and I know a lot of people that work hard.
- [Interviewer] What does
that mean, working hard?
What is your day like?
- Work hard is hustle all day long.
Talk about hustlers, Pete
Rose on the baseball field,
I try and do that all day long,
and that's what I think we
need to do here in America.
The people working in the
American automobile industry,
we got to out-hustle the Japanese.
We got to get that old roll up our sleeves
and get back to work.
Then we'll get this
country out of trouble.
We can do anything
better than anybody else
in the world, I think.
- [Interviewer] You bet your
life, there's no person--
- But we got to reawake that spirit.
That's what I'm trying to
do with the Atlanta Braves
is get everybody hustling,
'cause it sets a good example
for the people that are
watching the program.
- [Interviewer] You want another--
- Fear is the disease.
Hustle is the antidote, so, in my day,
I already sound like an old school dude.
In my day it was just tough, man.
You start a company in
2001, good luck, right?
You can't count on funding.
You can't count on sales.
You can't count on anything
but just crazy hustle
and just grit your teeth,
claw your way to success.
There was just no easy way to do it.
What I find is a lot of
the entrepreneurs today
are much smarter than
we were back in the day.
They're like way smarter.
They got blogs.
They know what VCs are doing.
They know everything that's
going on in the space.
There's a corpus of knowledge
now that makes entrepreneurs
today much smarter, but
there's liquidity in funding,
especially on the angel side.
It used to be much harder
to get an angel deal done
than a series A deal.
Now, angel deals are a piece
of cake, but what happens is
I see a number of entrepreneurs
who don't have that hustle,
and they're afraid, and
they act out of that fear,
and, when you act out of that
fear, you make big mistakes.
An example might be doing
a preempted deal with a VC
thinking they're your friend.
An example might be not being
hardcore in keeping your job.
An example might be,
a lot of times it gets
exposed through deals.
You see that fear being
exposed through the deal cycle,
and, if you're an entrepreneur
and you find yourself
afraid of something, sack up, okay,
and start hustling.
Hustling is the antidote to fear.
Go create your success.